Afghan police say at least three people
have been killed and 11 others wounded
an explosion near a football ground in
the eastern province of costs no one has
claimed responsibility for the attack
just a day earlier though the Taliban
said it would relaunch operations
against the Kabul government after
President Ghani refused the committed
terms of a peace deal between the US and
the Islamist group the reduction in
violence has ended now and our
operations will continue as normal as
per the u.s. Taliban agreement our
Mujahideen will not attack foreign
forces but our operations will continue
against the Kabul administration forces
I would caution everybody to think that
there's going to be an absolute
cessation of violence in Afghanistan
that is probably not gonna have its
we're not gonna go to zero we're pulling
out of Afghanistan is still very much
Donald Trump's goal - that's despite
Monday's setbacks we're getting out we
want to get out we had good meetings
with the Taliban and we are going to be
leaving and we're gonna be bringing our
soldiers back home we've been there for
almost 20 years it's a long time we've
done a great job in terms of getting rid
of terrorists now it's up to other
countries to get rid of those terrorists
you